最近お風呂入らずに寝てしまう　風呂なう
わかるわー
すごいわかるわー
起きた後のお風呂って気持ちいいっすよね
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
はいというわけでただいまの時刻5時42分でございます
えーおはようございますの人はおはようございます
僕はおやすみなさいでございます
あのずっと編集してて気づいたらもう朝になってて
やべっ寝なきゃと思った時に急に思いついたんですけども
皆さん悪夢見たくないですか？
なんかそれはいい夢見れたら一番いいんですけども
あのいい夢見た後の起きた瞬間の虚しさってあると思うんですよ
あれが嫌だあぁぁあぁああぁぁ
ってことは逆に考えると
あの悪い夢悪夢を見た後に起きると
っは　はぁはぁ
はぁーっていうこの安堵感に僕は襲われたいが故に
というわけでネットを使って悪夢の見方を色々調べてみました
なんかですね思ったより悪夢を見る方法って様々で
そのーなんかねあの地味にホラー映画とか好きなんで
なんか悪夢見たいんすよ
悪夢を見る方法が何個かあるので
是非悪夢を見たい方参考にしてみてはいかがでしょうか
わかりますかね？この悪夢を見たい気持ち
ちなみにです僕子供の頃よく見ていた夢が
なんかおもちゃ屋さん、トイザらスみたいなおもちゃ屋さんにいる夢で
なんか知らないんですけどなんか戦争の時代なんですよ
なんか戦時中の時代で
なんかよく空から攻撃されててすごい怖い夢を見てたっていう
よくわかんない話を言ってみたところでございます
皆さまどのような悪夢を見たことがあるで＄＆〜％＊
悪夢を見る方法その1
えー寝る直前まで怖い話のサイトを読む
なるほどホラー映画、心霊写真、ホラー漫画なんでもいいから
怖いものに囲まれれば囲まれるほど
怖い夢を見やすくなるらしいです
これがその1
その2
胸を圧迫して眠る
なるほど心臓のちょっと上ら辺に手を置いて眠ると
心臓が圧迫されて苦しくなる
やっぱ苦しくなるとね悪夢見やすくなるらしいです
その3
嫌な香りで眠る
あっ！
ぴったりな物があった
その4
幽霊やモンスターを想像しながら眠りにつく
なるほどなるほど
その5
寒い場所や寒暑い場所で眠る
あーやっぱりなんか不快な環境下で寝ると悪夢を見やすいみたいですね
その6
他の人が見た怖い夢を参考にさせてもらう
他の人の悪夢の体験談を脳内に情報として入れておくことによって
怖い夢を見やすくなる傾向にあるみたいでございます
うーん　結構色んな方法あるみたいなんですけども
これを全部まとめてやってみると果たして悪夢が見れるかどうか
検証していきたいと思います
え、やばい（小声）
ヤバイヤバイヤバイヤバイヤバイヤバイヤバイ
やばいあーもったいねーし（ピー）ね
ま、まぁーそうなっちゃいますよ
もう嫌な匂いってつったらそうなっちゃいますよ
うわあああ
待ってやだー　やだーーー
やべーうわー久しぶりだぁ
ウエェェ
他人が見た怖い夢か
私は夢を見ていました…
鳥肌やべぇー
あっつ　くっさ　待って環境が最悪
ウゥ　くさっ
モンスターモンスター
モンスターのイメージモンスターのイメージ
はいというわけで寝る準備ができました
あとは寝る直前まで話の怖いサイトを読みながら
胸をちょっと圧迫しながら寝て
幽霊やモンスターを想像しながら寝れば
悪夢がかなりの確率で見れるらしいです
ちょっと全部試していきます　おやすみなさい
はぁ　あー胸の圧迫感がすごい
ウ゛エー  ウ゛ェー　ウ゛ェ
あっつ！あとは怖い話を見ながらモンスターのことを考えればいいんやな
寝ていきましょうおやすみなさい　待って具合悪
ナレーション：はじめ）
彼はどんな悪夢を見ているのだろうか
驚くことに
彼は睡眠状態なのに
危険を察知したのか
ゲロの出る液体に手を触れた
そして
目覚めてしまった
これは偶然なのだろうか　必然なのだろうか
彼はそれを明らかにするように
なんと…
彼はもう一度
ゲロの出る液体に
手を触れた
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング】